got more now on former vice president
joe biden who is raising record amounts
of cash for the final push to election
day
ed o'keefe reports now on how the
campaign is stepping up its efforts
with only 19 days to go joe biden is now
sitting on a record-sized campaign war
chest 383 million dollars raised in the
month of september alone
and top aides say there's a total of 432
million dollars
still in the bank that's more money i've
ever raised my whole
my whole life how the biden campaign
plans to spend the money is unclear
but this week alone it's spending more
than 24 million dollars to advertise on
tv
in 16 battleground states even on
wednesday biden was raising money at a
private virtual fundraiser
and will do so again today before
appearing tonight at a televised town
hall meeting with voters
meanwhile biden running mate kamala
harris is stepping up her campaign
schedule
you can't shake hands but but you can
look people in the eye
and you can listen and you can be there
fresh off three days of confirmation
hearings for supreme court nominee amy
coney barrett
harris makes stops today in asheville
and charlotte north carolina
as early voting begins in the tar heel
state she heads to houston in the coming
days as biden continues closing the gap
in texas
where already nearly 1 million votes
have been cast
and then there's former president barack
obama hey georgia
barack obama here he's expected to
campaign for biden in the closing days
of the election in key battleground
states
appearing on the popular pod safe
america podcast he had a message for
democrats discouraged by party leaders
not pushing harder for more liberal
priorities
it's just that we don't yet have the
votes and the clout
so progressives you if you want
progressive legislation get out there
and keep working after the president is
elected
meanwhile early voting numbers are
coming in from states that are already
casting ballots and they are huge places
like california florida georgia michigan
and virginia
already 16 million plus votes are in
shattering records from 2016. gail
yeah people are showing up thank you
very much ed